pourquoi attendre qu'un musicien ne soit
plus de ce monde pour lui rendre hommage
c'est cette question que se pose d'un
adepte la dose chez patrick rey ellison
sur le parvis de la chapelle où viennent
de se tenir les obsèques de narmine
ducap tous les musiciens de l'époque les
orchestres qui faisait tourner les
carrousel sont aussi venus dire adieu à
leurs dalons et bien l'hommage désormais
n'attendra plus la mort mais la fête se
fera avec les vivants en présence de
tous ces artistes de talent qui ont
défendu la musique réunionnaise des
années 40 aux années 80 c'est sur la
scène du théâtre de champ fleuri et dans
le cadre des 70 ans de la
départementalisation que le séga
quadrilles polkas et la variété
retrouveront toute leur jeunesse
tu sais les uns clairement des musiciens
si tous les mois quelquefois deux fois
quelques fois des trois jeux de suite
si tout le temps ménard mines certes un
électrochoc parce qu'on s'attendait pas
on avait des projets en ce moment de les
faire un truc avec roger carr beit où il
était venu à la maison
personne n'attendait narmine est parti
en quinze joueurs tapent pouf saleté et
on s'est dit nick purée ça peut arriver
à n'importe lequel les plus vieux les
plus jeunes
et qu'est ce qu'on est en train de
perdre là
cette mémoire ses connaissances et tout
ça christian baptisto jacqueline
farreyrol régissent la caille pierrette
payet michou micheline picot encore joe
lorette en club et mariam en deux mots
tout est de manger autant d'artistes qui
sont à la fiche de cette soirée les
halons carrousel des vedettes pays qui
rendent hommage aux musiciens des
orchestres populaire parmi les têtes
d'affiché jean pierre boyer
quand je me lève être que ça m'a
contacté pour cet hommage
je me suis dit mais pourquoi pas en plus
gelé décider de ma chanson je n'attends
pas qu'il ferme les yeux plus offert des
fleurs et ça c'est un truc que j'ai
toujours pensé ils ont évidemment
l'idéal de le faire et je souhaitais
dans le train parce que je voyais pas
refusez ça parce qu'on me dise et
bernadette tout à l'heure c'est pas
quand la personne est décédée on rend
hommage
ça sert à rien il est plus là il à moi
je suis content de rendre hommage à tous
les dalons là le samedi 11 juin
est ce une façon à nous de rendre
hommage à van avant qu'il soit parti
rendre hommage mais surtout faire la
fête c'est pour cela qu'ils seront tous
réunis sur la scène du théâtre de champ
fleuri
une belle soirée à laquelle participera
jonquière la scène grand défenseur de la
musique réunionnaise
je crois que ça commençait avec
l'enterrement d'armes on dormait on a
commencé à réfléchir à ça à dire parce
qu'on sait jamais c'est pas forcément
les gens les plus vieux qui partent en
premier en séries quand même c'est moche
les gens partent et à l'orée
préférentiellement les plus âgés donc
bon c'est ce que bernadette a expliqué
la démarche a commencé avec patrick
raelison dit l'organisation de cette
journée au colorado et puis les coups
ç'a pris de l'ampleur et on se retrouve
maintenant ici grâce à l'abs
ovation de
du théâtre et le basque allons refaire
des parents
sur la scène du théâtre de champ fleuri
la nouvelle génération de musiciens sera
également présente pour reprendre le
flambeau de la tradition créole c'est
important parce que ça contribue à la la
la transmission d
musique des traditions dirais que c'est
plutôt une chance moi on a eu l'habitude
de jouer seul essai
en classique ou en traditionnel
on n'a jamais joué avec d'aussi grands
artistes et surtout de voir tous les
articles de la réunion réunit c'est une
chance pour une soirée avec des chansons
de la danse mais aussi un bal populaire
qui débutera dès la fin du concert sur
le parvis du théâtre de champ fleuri
un grand moment d'émotion et surtout les
retrouvailles de tous ces musiciens qui
ont navigué dans toutes les formations
de l'époque pour une fois et projecteurs
ne s'arrêteront pas seulement sur les
vedettes les belles et bien sûr tous
ceux sans qui il n'existerait même
bardet